I normally really don't tell the story
about how we started the company because
it's kind of awkward but it has a point
to to the things I want to talk about
today so so here goes
I met my co-founder the first time as I
walked up in a hot che bed on a cruise
ship in my boxers and so the PR folks
don't enjoy too much when I tell that
story and I kind of had to take their
hand over the duvet and said hi my name
is Henrik we were at a conference and is
vv or a little bit of the cheap hustler
then you could pick a ticket where you
were basically randomly paired up with
somebody else and I had picked that
ticket and so had my co-founder Matt and
and so he went to bed early before he
kind of came to the room I thought they
pushed the bets a pot but I thought it'd
be hilarious to put the best back
together so so he went to bed early I
went to bed late and so the first time
we ever met was in this very romantic
setting the reason why I want to tell
the story is because that I think it's
really changed the way that we built
bark we never really thought it would be
a very big business I really wanted to
work with Matt and my other co-founder
collie and we had these dogs that we
really loved and we didn't think there
was any cool thing there but we thought
you know how big is is the this how big
can that market be probably not too big
and so we kind of just did it for our
own dogs it turned out that we stumbled
into an industry that hadn't seen a lot
of innovation for a very long time there
is a ton of dogs in the u.s. roughly 48
percent of households have a dogs and
it's an industry that really haven't
seen a lot of innovation so in the last
few years you've seen some very big
transactions coming out of that space
she would being bored
Blue Buffalo being bored and
what-have-you and so we walked into this
industry where there was a few time
makes that have changed it was very big
it hasn't they hadn't seen a lot of
innovation and and then you know like we
we felt that we could do something there
what also have changed was that people
had really changed their relationship to
dogs dogs are no longer just a pet that
lies out in the in the garden it's
really a pet that is part of our family
and so maybe I can just like get a raise
of hands who have a dog or used to grow
up with a dog and and any cat people if
you could leave the room please
sneaky cat people so the relationship we
have with dogs have really changed you
know they now live in our bedrooms a
third of all dog owners lie in an
uncomfortable position to make sure the
dog is having a good time my Labrador
kind of like lies on the bed it's kind
of like spreads all over and 83% of them
kind of a-c-c their dog that's their
best friends as I certainly do and so
that was really like how our business
grew up over the last five to six years
I have a little video that I think gives
a good expression impression of what we
are doing beside the box I'd like to
play for you dogs
wagons flute and beg and tootin tug and
doof and fetch and stretch and snack and
scratch and lick and dig and sniff and
snug and smooch and huggin dogs do they
make life better
every person thinks they have the best
dog in the world and we agree with all
of them we're barb the company dedicated
to making dogs as happy as they make us
and dogs make us really happy Park was
started by these guys because of these
guys love those guys in 2012 they
created Barlow's you're hoping the
barkbox for the help me the first
subscription service meet just four dogs
barking five years and 60 million
products later
making way more than the box
mark helps pop parents make good healthy
decisions for their dogs because
everything we ship out must first be
play tested and approved by upper
management bark makes the most original
cutting-edge state of the fart dog stuff
imaginable and the most thoughtful
trustworthy lip-smacking dog snacks on
earth look we're just a bunch of crazy
dog people and like you we know that
dogs are way more than pets their family
and they deserve the best the best toys
the best treats the best life we can
give them at bark we want to be the
people our dogs think we are so we're
gonna keep our eyes on the ball and
follow our dogs lead by always
remembering what they've taught us be
good make time for play and for dogs
sake treat yourself thank you so here's
to the serious part of the conversation
because that we never thought it was a
would be a big thing we kind of build in
an assumption every time we do something
new that it won't work and I think
that's very much different than a lot of
the other startups that I've been part
of in the past where you kind of sold
this big dream to a lot of different
people and therefore it kind of has to
work but if you take a little bit like
an academic approach what really
happened there so you have a coal fesus
and then you go out in the market and
you try to see if that thesis is
actually valid or not and so that's very
much the approach that we have and so
what I brought today was a few examples
of the ways of how we try to kind of
assume that we will fail but that also
allow us to create a lot of new products
very quickly and not be too sentimental
about them if they work or not and so we
have a very good way of I feel taking
kind of extreme care activities and a
very data based approach and then really
merge those two together that gives us
the opportunity to become more creative
because that we are very kind of
ruthless about things that don't work
and then we move on for that and so the
most depressing stat I could find was
basically this one we're gonna fail
whatever we do the stats are pretty a
pretty bad if you beat like a book like
obviously blanking on the books name
right now Thinking Fast and Slow they
make a very good case I think about how
most projects will kind of like have a
rabid regression to the mean and so we
shouldn't have too much bias to think
that we can change that what we can do
is that we can reduce the cost of trying
so that really the opportunity and the
investment is not as high and that's
like a principle that we very much
taking to heart and so we really try to
have this mantra of trying to reduce the
pain of feeling and then really trying a
lot of different things by we choose the
try at the cost of trying I brought a
few examples basically how we built the
the Box first I'll tell you a little bit
about the first few days of that I have
two new products that we haven't really
announced a lot of the projects that we
built we
you don't go out and make PR around them
we test them with data before we think
they're kind of ready but these two is
kind of ready so I thought it'd be fun
for you guys to see them and so I'll go
through a different then this is the
first side it was called doggy back I'm
from Denmark and my English is not that
well and so I thought it'd be funny to
call it doggy baggie and my co-founder
telling me that you can totally not say
that in the US and so it became barkbox
instead this was the first version that
I had had mate it was basically a
wordpress template that I'd hacked
together and so the way that we got
about making the the starting the
business was that I made this template
showed it to a few people and most of
the time when I was showing it to people
they were saying hey that sounds super
cool please sign me up when you're ready
now I also had Square on my phone so I
was like you can just give me your
credit card and I'll be good to take
your money right now
so the first 67 accounts or something
like that was was really just signed up
on on met cause and my phones we didn't
I didn't really have the technical skill
to understand how to implement a payment
system so this was basically my own
little mock-up ball Simek mock-up went
to you know vendor designer comm and got
it to make it look pretty and and then
put it on a wordpress template so we
could show it around on our phones this
next kind of like I think interesting
thing about scaling and and preparing to
fail was that everybody then was asking
me the question when I had when we had
started then actually taking money from
people's like how you gonna scale
packing the boxes and and I said well
I'm gonna pack them myself and most
people say well that won't scale at all
and I kind of was I understand that
might be a problem but right now I have
68 accounts and it's relatively easy and
all the way up to the first two thousand
accounts we would have these patent
Patties this is my dear wife on the Left
that I'm bribing with red wine on date
night and so we would basically invite
our friends on on the last Thursday and
every month to come and drink wine and
eat cheese and then there'll be that
little surprise that they also had to
pack a few boxes
funny anecdote I don't spill very well
either so I wrote happy holidays with
two L's in two thousand boxes and my
co-founders thought I was an idiot but I
think it kind of like mixed a point we
didn't assume that this would be a very
big thing we didn't try to think about
how to get a 3pl which is a big packet
logistics center that we now need that
we'll be shipping you know hundreds of
thousands and millions of boxes and I
think this idea of really saying well
let's just go out and test some of these
things this is a good and valuable
exercise we check that into kind of like
even and micro level these are our poop
acts that are coming out the summer and
so we thought it would be fun to make
kind of like poo Buganda which is basic
like these statements where you can put
the hand in the poop bag and then you
can make a statement before you're
picking up now I don't know which
one of those that most funny and and so
we will often sit in meetings and have
this very kind of like conversation
about what is fun and not what it's not
fun and what we tend to do is that we
say well let's just try to test it a
little bit let's assume that we don't
have the answer and let's assume that
nobody will actually like any of it and
so what you can see in the top is a
little ad campaign that we've been
running just on the mock-ups for all
these different products and so these
different I think these are some of the
kind of like rap kind of inspired stuff
or maybe these of the poop again anyway
these are some of the the different it's
only actually I remember the first one
we we were doing we're doing this
localized and so for example the top one
that's called rent that was a statement
about like the rent is too high in in
New York and so probably the same in San
Francisco I hear and so that is the one
that was performing the well and it goes
back to this kind of like general
principle of like let's not assume that
what we are doing it's working let's
find a way of making sure that we can
test it as quickly as we can the final
thing I wanted to show you is this idea
of chompers Club Chomper Club is another
product that we haven't known
yet and I'll give you a little bit of
the background around around that a lot
of you have dogs know that you should be
brushing the teeth of your dog every day
but we don't really do that and so we
wanted to try to come up with a new way
that we can create dental hygiene for
dogs but in a fun way and so we came up
with this idea of basically creating
toys that had this basic toothpaste and
science so when the dogs are playing
with the toys then they can do that now
we're obviously a bigger company now
we're 400 people and so even if we feel
that we are still a startup you start to
get like the dynamics of a bigger
company built into the DNA of the
organization and so you will have like
our marketing team getting very nervous
about how when we launch something new
we can protect our brand you'll have the
tech team that's very nervous about how
this will work into their roadmaps and
stuff like that and so we take a very
deliberate approach of launching
everything as they're independent units
and so each of these new things that
we're launching they are basically
startups within our startups and we hire
new full-stack teams to basically launch
them and we do that because we think
there's a very decent chance as these
things will fail and so we have a lot of
those conversations internally and to be
honest often like it creates a little
bit of kind of like a bad dynamics
because people get a little bit
frustrated that we take one part of a
business and turn it into new things but
we feel really in today's age where the
half lifetimes of products and marketing
campaigns are getting so short
you're really key competitive advantages
is to be able to launch something very
quickly and take decision very quickly
and empower teams to really move as as
quickly as they can and so we do that
other thing this is as mentioned cold
chompers Club it's a new product we have
coming out if you search for it online
you'll find it and we've had it up and
running for two or three months you'll
notice that there's no bog branding on
it at all inside and that is really
because that that team is a completely
separate team that we're running
independently and first when we think
that we have the product completely
right that we have the cocktail TV in
the in the position that we really want
then we integrate it back into the
family of brands and and then we we kind
of like push the pedal to the metal on
that but let me show you a little bit of
the product
puppy breath ah dog breath offensive dog
breath stinks and that's just the
beginning
here at bark we hear from millions of
dogs and their motto every time a
painter
they have a lot in common a love of
snacks a hatred of squirrels and dental
problems serious dental problems these
dental problems can be prevented by
brushing your dog's teeth daily but
you're not doing that no one is over 90%
of dogs get severe oral disease in their
lifetimes gross dog breath is often a
sign of deeper problems tooth decay gum
disease serious infection safely
treating your dog's dental health
problems can easily cost $1,000 per year
let's clean it up introducing chompers
Club we're making it easy to keep your
dog's teeth in tip-top shape wrestle
with a toothbrush bribe with treats no
you don't need to work that hard anymore
with chompers Club canine oral hygiene
is just another flavor of fun here's how
it works we've developed a convenient
subscription with an innovative new
toothpaste for dogs its enzymatic
translation it's loaded with tons of
special tummy safe enzymes that break
down the bacteria in your dog's mouth
that cause tooth decay and oral disease
it's also delicious
we designed special dog toys engineered
to scrub your dog's teeth while they
play you apply the enzymatic toothpaste
to the toy and give it a toss while your
dog is busy chewing our toothpaste is
busily eating away at the tartar and
plaque on their teeth that's it you're
done when you join chompers Club we send
you everything you need as often as you
need
give your favorite Chomper healthy teeth
chompers Club
[Music]
so a lot of these things that now we
make them as human great I have actually
brushed my teeth in this it is different
to have a bacon flavor toothpaste than
what you normally used to it is pretty
delicious but the the most probably
right now is the chicken so so that's
the one we're sending out and so I think
really for me yeah this is the site and
as you can see there's none of the
branding in there and it's definitely
one of the things that's created some
conflicts but we very much believe that
the way that we've been able to
continuously build your products get
them out of the market is to have this a
little bit kind of non-conventional
methodology and how we do it and assume
that we're gonna fail before that we
have these fail a few times because
before we come see me succeed and so
basically the Cole kind of like messes
you have the three of what three of them
the three kind of stories was I built
this company together with two friends
and we kind of assumed because you know
we didn't know better that it might not
work at least I really adore my
co-founders and so every day that's a
little bit hot it's really enjoyable
because I can think back of lying on
hardship but no because that I can enjoy
how cool they are
I think really taking data-driven design
and find a way of minimizing the cost of
putting new products out there is
something that's worked very well for us
and then I think you need to
increasingly see yourself as being a
system of creative systems thinker when
it comes to launching new things because
that products lifetime are getting
shorter and because new channels and how
you grow is becoming easier and easier
to copy and so we see our business very
much as somebody who really loved dogs
and then really created like a very cool
platform for building a lot of things
that make dogs happy I hope you enjoyed
the presentation
[Applause]
[Music]